[Music]
because our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do just
two more days until Wonder Woman hits
theaters now the movie is getting rave
reviews and I can attest to the fact
that the film star gal gadot is every
bit as impressive in person as she is on
screen but you know what there's a lot
about her that will surprise you we
tracked gals rise from mere mortal to a
superhero stay here I'll go ahead she is
about to become a household name but
turns out her parents changed the
original family name the gadot used to
be Greenstein it wasn't me they did it
but I liked it better
born and raised in Israel as is the
custom she enlisted in the military
after high school you were in the army
I was so like this Wonder Woman thing
you're ready for it's funny I was ready
this is the role of my dreams ever since
I became an actress I wanted to show the
stronger side of women gal is 32 years
old about 5 feet 10 inches tall married
and the mother of two daughters Alma and
mine her husband since 2008 his real
estate developer your own bar Sato
before acting she was a beauty queen
crowned Miss Israel in 2004 she became a
model which led to an acting career her
first big role was in Fast Five from The
Fast & Furious series hurts herself they
don't allow me to drive fast in the
movie I had a white Porsche and they
told me to keep it on the first gear her
first appearances Wonder Woman came in
last year's Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice I don't think you've ever known
a woman like me gal played a spy in
keeping up with the Joneses with Jon
Hamm but the excitement was building for
the film that just might make her a
superstar shooting this movie Wonder
Woman was such a unique beautiful
amazing experience I just can't wait to
share it all with you by the way early
projections have Wonder Woman earning
somewhere north of 100 million dollars
worldwide it's opening the weekend it's
a wonder
you